he's been accused of being illiterate
and in fact the the first credit bureau
in America called the mercantile agency
which is actually the ancestor of dun
bradstreet
when it first reported on Vanderbilt in
Vanderbilt was born in 1794 so this
first report about him actually came in
his late 50s and yet you know this is
kind of mid-career for Vanderbilt very
long life it called him illiterate in
boorish offensive and vulgar and yet he
actually was not illiterate he could
read perfectly well and he could write
but he wrote phonetically so for example
his early letters had not only would
every word be misspelled I found some
letters in which he misspelled the same
three letter word three different ways
in the same letter in his early letters
he wrote very much as he spoke so his
very lack of education allows us to gain
access to the pattern of speech he had
even the pronunciations of certain words
for example I found this in other
letters some people around this time
early 19th century New York they would
often add an A before a verb ending in
ing so for example mr. Jones's are going
to Albany things are all working he
would use constructions that are would
be familiar today if he ought to have
been he would write he oughta bean would
be the way he dried it out as he aged he
shifted a lot of the writing to a clerk
and yet the letters that survived in his
own hand show that his speech actually
became more formal that as he began to
circulate in a more refined layer of
society due to his wealth and his
business connections his and we know
also from newspaper interviews as well
his actual speech became more formal and
more correct and some of the letters are
very interesting written in his own hand
for example when Cyrus field
who was from a very socially prestigious
family
the man who pioneered the transatlantic
Telegraph cable he invited Vanderbilt
over for dinner in the 1850s around the
time of this credit report that
condemned him is illiterate and vulgar
and Vanderbilt wrote a note back
declining and it's very interesting
because the note says I in his own hand
I regret to inform you that I must
decline in consequence of an engagement
I've previously made a very correct
formal note almost every word misspelled
but a very formal and correct note and
this showed this is Vanderbilt you know
we never had a classical education forum
allege ocation let alone classical and
yet he actually began to affect the
dignity that his his wealth lifted him
to that that status and that level of
society in debt at the same time it's
possible for example that he was
dyslexic
that's a diagnosis I can't really
formally make in a book because of the
distance of time but it's possible that
he had some sort of reading disabilities
such as dyslexia
well first of all I doubt that he would
have read it he didn't do a lot of
leisure reading most of his leisure
activities involve something competitive
perhaps if he was in a race with someone
to read it to who could read it fast as
he migrated but I think that Vanderbilt
was someone who you know he let the
chips fall where they may
I think that he would feel that some of
my discussions about the way Americans
saw him and argued about him might be a
bit too much of verbiage he didn't like
people who who said too much but I tried
to present a very fair and honest
portrait of him and expressed the the
fact that he was controversial for
important reasons he was very familiar
with the public debate about him
throughout his career and what he
represented for good and for ill in
American society
and yet at the same time I made clear
that his contemporaries especially those
who really dealt with him in business
including his enemies felt that he had
earned his pride in himself he was a
very proud man wasn't boastful but he
was very proud and you know he often for
example befriended his enemies after
usually after he'd crush them in a
business battle then later they would
become card-playing partners and this
shows that you know not only did he not
take things personally but that he had
sort of a good sportsmanship attitude
toward business battles he would fight
with every weapon available to him and
yet he lived by a code as ruthless as it
was it was a code and as a corporate
manager he was honest as much as he
represented a new power in corporations
and so you know I tried to bring that
out the fact that he was a man that
everyone respected even when they
opposed him and I think that's something
that he would take great pride in so I
you know the valuable descendants for
example who I've spoken
who've read my book have really felt
like it was a really fair portrait and
and that's the best I can ask for